en 2016 le festival a mis en place des
règles strictes
les bouteilles sont vides et à l'entrée
et plusieurs sont refusés sur le site
comme les bouteilles rigide des mesures
mises en place pour des questions de
sécurité pour ne pas que les gourdes
rigide soient lancées dans la foule ou
sur scène
soucieuse de l'environnement cette
festivalière venus de la région de
l'outaouais n'en revient pas de cette
mesure
elle a écrit au feq j'aurais dit il faut
faire confiance aux festivaliers on
apporte sur par souci pour
l'environnement
et si quelqu'un a déjà je fait le
mauvais choix de lancer quelque chose
sur la scène est blessé quelqu'un je
pense pas que ça justifie de bannir
toutes les bouteilles du julie s'égayent
n'est pas la seule à dénoncer cette
politique le conseil régional de
l'environnement estime aussi que le
festival doit faire mieux
visiblement ya pas assez de fontaines
sur le terrain on voit que les gens font
des lignes interminables et finissent
par se décourager et en plus le fait que
les gens puissent pas amener leurs
gourdes habituel ce qu'ils sont habitués
à traîner le lait les gourdes rigide bah
non c'est soit c'est un problème parce
que les gens se font avoir songé de
racheter sur le terrain une bouteille
jetables donc qu'hier encore une étape à
faire à ce niveau là on a reçu plusieurs
commentaires à cet effet le puits nous
mêmes
ça fait déjà un petit bout de temps
qu'on se questionne à propos de ce
règlement le l'organisation est prête à
revoir ses façons de faire pour la
prochaine édition
on peut peut servir le bar pour 2019 qui
est beaucoup trop tard pour se re on est
déjà
bien en selle mais pour 2020 c'est
certain qu'on va vouloir prêter une
attention particulière à sa puis on va
essayer de rétablir le règlement faut
mettre ça en place de nos jours on peut
plus passer à côté des choses aussi
importantes que le feq dans une ville
aussi importante il faut que ce soit un
leader faut que ça montre l'exemple
on ne sait pas encore quelles seront les
nouvelles règles la réflexion est en
cours mais quand julie séguin il
reviendra au festival l'an prochain elle
pourra certainement accéder au site
avec sa propre bouteille ici ghislaine
bus et à radio canada québec